foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty Swenson writer
for Lords of gaming and with me today is
my partner in crime Lord King
we are back once again talking about
She-Hulk and this week as Jennifer
Walters put it is a self-contained
wedding episode with no big States
whatsoever or so they lead you to
believe because we did get a little
something to move the plot forward I'm
going to toss it over to you King on
what you were thinking with this uh
wedding episode slash divorce and
everyone's going to court nowadays well
first I I want to congratulate you on
becoming scribe of the month ah yes yes
I didn't get a chance to do it you know
send a great video and the video was
fantastic so if anybody uh didn't get a
chance to see that go check that out uh
my man here scribe tomorrow
so I'm sitting here with the best
uh this episode okay so coming into this
episode I had High Hopes on seeing a
certain other lawyer of a red persuasion
well red and yellow persuasion now that
he's in MCU yeah I got that tease and um
it wasn't to be so uh
you know it we did get a chance to see
one of her uh dresses that was made from
the super Taylor yeah for the for the
for the superheroes and um
it wasn't it was a nice dress it fit her
so well and she looks so beautiful
showing up when her friend uh asked her
to come to the wedding
and it was always
ulterior motives so you understood
exactly where she stood in the pantheon
of her friends on how her friends was
treating her and how
um the bride actually treated her
because the bride
she was just like the butt of the jokes
to be honest with you and she she wanted
to keep the tradition going as her being
the butt of the jokes
um you know right now she's financially
stable she's a Superhero and it's it's
she's you know living high on a hawk so
she shows up at She-Hulk and you know uh
the bride is like yo come on you like
taking my shine like you know
so she asked it you know to make a a a
deal with her that she doesn't be
She-Hulk at the wedding
to take the genre and you know Jennifer
is such a humble nice friend that she
decides not to do so
oh and to Titania uh how the hell did
she get there and she's like yo she only
showed up here just just to you know to
interject herself into my life to make
my life miserable yeah like and how come
nobody sees this and yeah it was
absolutely nuts
um long story short you know her cousin
is always around he's the DJ he's always
doing something to make some money I
like this kid this kid is he's he's an
entrepreneur he's trying he's what's his
name MC Hulk or something like that the
enchantable Hulk and should have walked
he it was it was it was nuts it was that
was good and and
now on the other end you know before I
even delve into the the main event fight
on the other end we got um a a character
from the MCU that is he he's like a joke
character like
um what's his what's his name Mr Mr
Immortal Immortal and
he can die
all right so I mean in MCU they did find
in the comic books they did find a way
to kill him but
um this one they just showed they were
showing and I loved how She-Hulk shows
it everyday life of supers and what
they're showing is with the She-Hulk
there are other supers around
and people are used to it so it's it's
not like oh my God he's a super and
stuff like that when he jumps out the
window and hits the car and he just gets
up you know and cracks his body and you
know he walks off
that showed and they weren't freaking
out they was like oh so that's how it
works type of thing it's a regular
occurrence with the She-Hulk series and
they're getting you used to supers on
every corner stuff going around without
people panicking and actually they are
like they're celebrities type of things
so back to Titania and She-Hulk I
couldn't believe Titania snuff Jennifer
I like I really couldn't believe that
and and Jennifer didn't have no ill
effects that was kind of baffling to me
did she pull up punch when she hit her
uh what what is what is Titania's uh
punch range like what's what's going on
what is her power range I I need to know
this because she's going toe-to-toe with
the She-Hulk when you know Jennifer said
you know enough is enough I'm going to
turn into She-Hulk and she tried and she
cutting that first and then she was like
I forgot how to do it and then she
actually turns into a but they go you
know one-on-one
and everybody just takes out the phone
nobody's running
they'll just take out their phone while
these two soups is actually fighting and
they're going viral and some terrible
happens to Titania that's really
terrible for influencer and a person
worried about their image the absolute
worst thing happened to her but I'm like
this was the episode of normalcy like
nobody was shocked nobody was amazed and
we're going to the day-in-day lives of
superheroes getting divorced going to
weddings getting into fights that
nobody's running away from and they're
standing there and I'm like wow this
episode's they episodes keep showing you
more and more into the MCU and where the
MCU is going and what they're trying to
do and I think to She-Hulk uh series is
a key vehicle in doing that and pushing
that narrative forward
yeah so this week's episode with it
being centered around more daily living
day-to-day type of deals uh Jennifer
getting invited to the wedding and I
kind of already knew what was up because
it was an old friend that you know kind
of hung out with during school it feels
being like nah nah I like to I moved out
cut ties no I'm not going to no family
reunion School reunion you don't need to
invite me not going to be there but you
know she being nice is like oh well like
I got an invite I gotta show up I'm a
bridesmaid
um and I liked her uh showing up on the
scene excited to Showcase her new dress
because this is this is the beginning of
her coming out of her shell and being
more excited to show off her figure show
off and be proud of the things that she
has done accomplished as she mentioned
later in the show like you know I'm
actually doing great like I have powers
great paying job you know I get to work
with my best friend every day you know
life is good
and for Lulu the the bride to be like
you know it's my big day if you could
just like
ixnay on the hulky yeah uh like I was
mad for Jennifer and but like you said
she was nice and she went ahead and went
back to Jen and I thought it was an
interesting plot point that
the joke for this episode was just Jen
the title of suggestion that she
was primarily trying to beat just
Jennifer Walters in favor of Saving
Grace with the bride but this is
probably the first time that she
willingly
um showed up unprompted as She-Hulk
because when it came to the Tinder slash
um dating app thing uh someone told her
like hey her person was like Hey you get
a lot more likes if you did a She-Hulk
yeah but this was her own thinking of
like I'm gonna show up Ashley Hulk I'm
becoming proud of who I am
um so I very much appreciate that and in
this episode uh keeping in ties with
love she actually met someone in in
which I'm a little suspectful of this
dude yeah he's a little sauce and we'll
get to that
um Josh nice guy corny seems to be right
her speed
shows up oh good yeah yeah yeah like
almost almost like you know a match made
in heaven which is yeah which is very
suspectful especially when She-Hulk
herself is coming out of a lawsuit with
titanium which is public knowledge from
the court hearings that uh she had all
these guys that she dated she's trying
to find someone on a dating app you can
see She-Hulk is trying to find someone
so it's not very hard for someone with
ill intentions to be like if we want to
get a gut on the inside yeah that's how
we go and the reason why we're alluding
to this is because uh part of the
subplot B with Mr Immortal and his wives
that he's trying to you know get
scot-free from doing them wrong
um Jennifer's best friend and the in
Mallory the other like high-end lawyer
in the division find this like black
site Q Anon Type Beat of like you know
She-Hulk it's no good bad news death to
She-Hulk all this really bad stuff aimed
at her and we saw as the episode ended
that some itech lab of what we assumed
to be the people that are trying to get
she-hulk's blood I think his aim
okay so so aim aim or someone with that
caliber trying to get her blood is
actually working with this black site so
it's not just some neck beard in Mom's
basement doing all this this is like
really legit really legit bad news
because we see like the bent needle from
the first field attempt yep we see the
upgrading needle and we also see on the
security cams I think it's vibranium too
yeah we sit on the security cameras
Jennifer having that little nice date
with Josh as uh her phone's sent to
silent of hey like you know this
probably isn't about isn't a big thing
but you know there are people who want
to do ill to you so just watch out where
do you think that's going to lead going
to the next episode
um I don't know hopefully we get to see
more of the Wrecking Crew a little bit
more as guardian buffed up uh when they
do get their powers uh maximized uh
because they do get their enchanted
weapons you know maximized and they do
actually take on a different form
um I I love The Wrecking Crew so yeah
right they do come back
um and and actually to see the nefarious
uh intent I do want them to get the
blood to maybe we get a bomb
um maybe we get a red Hulk
um
Red She-Hulk uh different characters
with using the gamma radiated blood but
is the caveat in using her blood is the
fact that uh what Bruce alluded to uh
that there because they have a special
Gene that they're able to absorb the
gamma radiation because it would most
likely kill someone else someone else
exactly so are there mutants are they
leading to that because with Mr immortal
which I don't know if he's a mutant and
I have to double check but
the fact that they're so Cavalier with
the with other soups and there's a
tailor for the other soups and I didn't
go back and look at that episode where
the guy was leaving out and who the hell
was that that was leaving out with a
suit
uh and he's in good business he does a
lot of business right so who's next
what's next this stuff is all in the up
in the air because I really thought I
was gonna get Matt Murdock and and I
didn't or at least it's all to Ego so
it's still room to breathe and he's up
right right
yeah I'm glad you brought that back up
because that's probably the only other
thing it's with that fight with the
Tanya versus She-Hulk I'm like okay is
this gonna be a little bit higher stakes
and it wasn't really like Jennifer got
sucker punched a couple times but then
she transformed She-Hulk and then there
was a small bit of back and forth but
then she Hulk pretty much took the upper
hand and Titania took herself out onto
the cubes of ice
um but the few good licks that Titania
got and on She-Hulk I was hoping that
that was going to lead to and maybe this
might happen if aim or whoever has
another altercation with Jennifer but
then that Jennifer is going to learn how
to actually self-defend herself and not
just rely on brute strength of fighting
because the train that she had with
Bruce was really how to get a handle on
her powers there wasn't any really
technical this is how you fight if you
are in a life or death situation
right and that's what I'm hoping that
this kind of
will um simulate them working together
more is that Matt will offer to give
Jennifer some pointers whether we go
like The Arrow show uh style of where
Matt just shows like I haven't um don't
have super strength or anything but with
my sixth sense to martial arts I can
just smoke you like that anyone yeah
that knows what they're doing
um Can seriously do harm to you can't
just rely on your powers all the time
so hopefully that's exactly where it
goes and because she's supposed to get
some form of martial arts training so
will he be our instructor
you know right what's next and I think
everybody that's watching these episodes
are built up to the point that they're
waiting to see Daredevil because they
know Daredevil at some time is the big
payoff in one of these episodes and I
believe that Kevin feige and the team
understands that and they string us
along so well because we truly do not
know what each episode is going to be
yeah and I'm just hoping that that
the payoff
um in whatever capacity isn't safe to a
last episode as sometimes these things
are tend to happen and that we it has
room to breathe outside one episode
um whether it be the second to last or
just adequate time to build up those
relationships get State us enough
um so that we know for next time um
Daredevil reborn if you want more about
Murdoch that's where you got to be for
the next time
um because also you're gonna be bringing
new fans Who
Um this might be their first interaction
with Daredevil to a legitimate capacity
whether or not they they missed the
original Netflix show they a lot of
people saw Spider-Man
um no way home or um
yeah yeah and
um Matt Murdock being there for all of
Five Seconds to be Peter's lawyer and
some people were freaking out in
theaters and I was like yeah
like who's that why are we screaming so
I think think for those new people you
definitely want to
um put your best foot forward when
introducing that character in this show
yeah definitely 100 percent
well everyone let us know what you think
in the comments down below because this
has been the Lord's minute thank you so
much for joining us we're here every
Monday Wednesday and Friday at
lordsagaming.net
I'm ty Swenson here with Lord King and
this has been the Lord's minute peace
[Music]